j'accueille nadine morano
[Applaudissements]
alors nadine êtes députée ump de meurthe
et moselle mais aussi déléguée générale
de l'ump
c'est une blague c'est qu'ils ont des
conneries du one man show en clair vous
faites partie de la garde rapprochée de
nicolas sarkozy mais c'est pas
contagieux
non mais ça peut devenir non à force
d'arguments
voilà voilà bien sûr en tous les cas
vous êtes sa femme de terrain sa fille
des cités sont 4,4
non monsieur vous êtes la dimension
quand même populaire du sarkozysme oui
tout à fait des mois qu'on peut le dire
oui oui parce que moi j'ai une vraie
expérience de la vie densité puisque j'y
suis né justement et j'ai vécu jusqu'à
l'âge de 23 ans dans un domaine que je
connais bien
justement êtes né en 1963 à nancy dans
un milieu ouvrier vous avez vécu jusqu'à
23 ans au haut du lièvre la barre la
plus longue d'europe une ville immeuble
conçu pour abriter 900 familles d'abord
au cèdre bleu et ensuite au hêtre
pourpre et vous dit en parlant de cette
époque j'étais parfaitement heureuse
on avait tout pour être bien c'est vrai
qu'il y avait la première émigration on
va dire des ruraux qui sont arrivés en
ville dans les années 50 des
appartements extrêmement bien conçu avec
un grand balcon salle de bain à
l'intérieur de l'appartement ce qui
n'était pas le cas en milieu rural
puisque vous aviez la selle de 20 dans
le jardin les toilettes dans le jardin
la cité effectivement était neuf et
avait tout ce dont nous avions besoin et
la censure c'est l'ascenseur marché il y
avait un concierge dans chaque bâtiment
il y avait
le centre commercial deux centres
commerciaux les médecins le commissariat
de police
le collège il y avait aussi la piscine
olympique
cours de danse pour deux pianos cours de
couture c'était vraiment je crains une
cité où effectivement nous avions un
mélange d'ouvriers d'employés de
militaires une mixité sociale qui
fonctionnait plutôt bien et qui s'est
dégradée au fur et à mesure où on a
enlevé les moyens mon âme où on a les
militaires prenaient des cours de
couture tout ça non mais c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque il y avait trois familles
africaines sur les cités dont une qui
est devenue ma meilleure amie et qu'il
est toujours aujourd'hui et
c'est vrai que quand les appartements se
sont vidés parce qu'après une fois vous
gagner un peu d'argent bien vous achetez
votre pavillon en banlieue nancéienne à
clairions où elle soul / et puis ces
appartements ville et bien c'est vrai
que on les réserve et à tout ce qui
arrive est issu de l'immigration et on
en faisait des ghettos fur et à mesure
c'est vrai que on a vu la cité se
dégrader beaucoup plus vite aussi à ce
moment-là dévier des personnes dans le
désespoir qui avait pas de travail qui
avait pas le même respect des lieux
communs et y en a d'autres qui respecte
les lieux communs des mêmes règles
une intégration qui se faisait
difficilement nadine ce qu'on peut dire
effectivement c'est que vous avez pas
souffert de cette vie en cité vous dire
que l'épargné pas vié pas une âme de
rebelle pas une âme de gauchistes non
plus faut bien le dire et vous non pas
du tout et vos parents vous ne parliez
du général de gaulle vos parents vous
envoie chez les dominicaines à nancy oui
chez les soeurs n'a rien arrangé
évidemment ça vous a les amas non ça m'a
donné une vraie rigueur morale ça m'a
donné le goût de l'intérêt général et
j'avais vraiment envie de m'engager pour
les autres bon c'est vrai qu'à partir la
puberté je me suis dit soeur ça doit pas
être fait pour toi donc j'ai un peu
changé de cap et je me suis dirigé vers
l'action publique
votre mère était fille d'immigré italien
a été standardisant une compagnie de
taxis votre père chauffeur poids lourd
donc vraiment milieu ouvrier
mais pas du tout communiste 1 il y avait
du frittage avec les avec le communisme
avant tout parce que
c'est vrai qu'il y avait une pression
dans les cités avec des gens qui faisait
une propagande extrêmement intensive et
agressive je dirais qui ne convenait pas
je dirais aux valeurs que chercher mes
parents c'est à dire l'initiative
personnelle le goût du travail la
volonté de réussir de s'en sortir et ne
pas aller chercher chez les risques et
pour pouvoir enrichir impôts vraiment
l'égalité des chances à passer par le
travail on partait pas en vacances
n'était pas malheureux
donc je dire voilà alors qu'aujourd'hui
c'est vrai qu'on veut tout tout de suite
qu'on devient très matérialiste et qu'on
a perdu aussi un peu ses valeurs alors
que je voulais dire si à votre cheveu
d'eau si vous me le permettez le chardy
sont pas ce que je vous ai écoutés
lorsque j'étais dans la loge et c'est
vrai qu'on a toujours tendance à dire
que les choses sont compliquées qui a
des problèmes la société les jeunes les
plus vieux tous que vous en avez parlé
avec certains responsables politiques
que vous en avez discuté sans doute
votre notamment avec mon ami mais moi ce
que je voudrais vous demander est-ce que
vous avez suivi sur le fond pendant une
semaine à responsables politiques
notamment un parlementaire comme moi
pour voir quel était le travail qui
était fait dans la circonscription moi
c'est 180 communes 176 km de long
beaucoup de dossiers de collectivités
locales beaucoup de dossiers de citoyens
des textes législatifs du parti
politique aussi un peu et j'aimerais
vous inviter à venir si vous en êtes
d'accord
une semaine pour suivre vraiment lamine
sall était responsable politique en 2000
euros en seulement ici que vous puissiez
voir avant de dire compétences ou pas
compétence ou la droite pas vous parle
pas la gauche sait pas quoi devenir voir
concrètement arriver les dossiers
j'aurais bien placé une parce que c'est
sur cette nouvelle loi générale répond
je vous en prie d'abord un
je tombe pas dans le tous pourris je
suis beaucoup plus évidemment un secteur
beaucoup plus subtil
oui c'est pour ça que je vis à vis oui
c'est pourquoi depuis à peu près 35 ans
que j'arpente le pays
je vais non je veux dire que les
politiques et des politiques qu'est ce
que vous apprenez météo
à voir faire ça alors raison tu connais
quoi les d'anciens pouvoir en parler je
voudrais que vous connaissiez sur le
fond c'est arrivé le côté bobo le côté
goal com ya pour moi j'y vais dans les
quartiers mais c'est pas une question
d'y aller c'est parce india les mots si
je devais pas le dossier guetta pas les
dossiers que moi je voudrais qu'ils
voient concrètement ce qu'est le travail
d'un parlementaire
le courrier qu'il reçoit tous les jours
les dossiers qu'ils étudient les
suivants sont inhumaines non mais il me
vient de vivre il faut mais que des
problèmes et je veux pas vous les
rencontriez non je voulais passer avec
mes nerfs geographic
je pense que la digne de prendre avec
quelques semaines et je serais toi et
pas mal est là si ça et ça ça relève de
votre libido
je veux profiter quand il va être en
tournée quand il est du côté de nancy là
bas je pense qu'il va y aller la meurthe
et moselle dossier regardez-le est ouvre
du coup ils sont de rien bien alors
nadine je continue votre légende un jour
votre prof de droit député rpr de
meurthe-et-moselle vous engage comme
attaché parlementaire est là et vous
fait non et vous fait visiter
l'assemblée nationale et je voudrais lui
rendre hommage parce que il est décédé
il ya à peine quinze jours et donc je
voudrais lui rendre hommage parce que
j'ai beaucoup appris à ses côtés et ça a
été un parlementaire très travailleur
voilà et donc un jour il vous fait
visiter l'assemblée nationale et quand
vous arrivez dans l'assemblée nationale
vous verrez j'entrais dans une
cathédrale
voilà et là vous dit qu'un jour vous
serez députés ça n'a pas été facile et
les débuts au rpr ils sont calmes très
macho quoi oui il n'y a pas qu'au et
repères je dirais que ça continue encore
cette position il ya un mec qui vous a
dit un jour mais tu as du talent et vous
lui avez répondu mais qu'est ce que tu
croyais que j'étais une blonde
deux scènes
bon alors ça ça c'est le côté positif et
puis alors il ya le maire ps de toul
elle m'adore alors sarkozy au féminin
l'intelligence en moins oui mais je les
ai battus à 60% sur ta ville donc pas
laisser d'arrêt non elle dit simplement
vous êtes d'extrême droite quand même
hein vous savez ça oui mais elle a
complètement tort parce que c'est pas
vrai elle dit par exemple que vous avez
été le relais dans une campagne des
jeunesses identitaires pour
l'interdiction du du rappeur snippers
mais elle ment parce que quand vous
relisez la question que j'ai posée
officiellement dans l'hémicycle devant
les caméras de france 3 j'ai demandé
quelles mesures comptez prendre le
ministre de l'intérieur pour faire
respecter l'ordre public
je n'ai jamais demandé l'interdiction
d'un concert de groupes d'europe
j'ai demandé simplement le respect et le
respect de l'autorité
sarkozy vont tomber un peu mou non je
trouve très bien à vous êtes catholique
pratiquante mais vous êtes d'accord pour
l'adoption des enfants par des couples
homosexuels
moi je comprends plus rien il ya
ségolène royal qui veut mettre des
militaires dans les écoles vous vous
êtes pour l'adoption des enfants par les
homosexuels c'est bien compliqué la
politique comment pourquoi je suis à mon
sens le problème c'est que ségolène si
vous voulez ça me fait penser un peu à
venir l'aisne en ce moment c'est ainsi
de ses douces et 9 non la verbier avec
mir l'aisne
ces neuf noms proposés par ségolène
parce qu'il existe déjà mais donc voilà
alors vous l'adoption des enfants par
les homosexuels je comprends plus rien à
faire ici parce que je me suis aperçu
qu'en fait les homosexuels avaient des
enfants et donc moi j'estime que les
enfants doivent avoir les mêmes droits
que les miens et donc si une mère
biologique décède qu'elle est élevée par
sa concubine
que devient l'enfant qui va s'en occuper
qui va les chercher à l'école ou laver
son linge et donc il n'y a pas besoin de
faire une loi sur l'homoparentalité il
suffit juste de modifier l'article 365
du code civil et de l'adapter en
permettant aux personnes qui vivent en
concubinage ou aux personnes pacsées de
pouvoir adopter en adoption simple et on
règle les problèmes de sécurité pour ses
enfants
j'ai pas du tout soit ligne de christine
boutin par exemple qui elle aussi est
une catholique pratiquante
oui non je suis pas du tout sûr la mode
chez christine boutin parce que elle
estime qu'en fait on va vers un
changement de société
et c'est vrai que la posture qui avait
eu la droite au moment de la discussion
du pacs qui consistait à dire eh bien
avec le pacs
on aura moins de mariages - de naissance
on s'aperçoit qu'aujourd'hui le taux de
fécondité par femme est de 1,9 c'est à
dire le deuxième pays européen derrière
l'irlande donc les français font
toujours autant de bébés
les français se marient toujours autant
et le pacs a répondu à une attente
catégorie de la population qui en
avaient besoin alors en politique vous
souhaitez ouvertement le départ de
villepin oui vous avez dit ses effets de
manche se réalise font pas illusion là
où 1
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de qualités
mais je pense qu'il n'a pas comment
dirais-je le la façon d'être avec les
parlementaires qui qui sont qu'à un peu
de ménage entendu peuple quoi donc c'est
vrai que nous présenter un projet de loi
qui n'a pas été présenté devant les
parlementaires arrivée par amendement
bon je dire c'est des discussions entre
nous je veux dire c'est vous savez que
c'est la seule prérogative bordel vous
savez à gauche alors n'en parlons même
moi maintenant je vais te dire le
couperet moment je pense que ce qui est
important ce qui ouvre les dossiers toi
c'est essentiel déjà presque et ce sont
les résultats qu'obtiennent notre pays
en matière de croissance en matière de
lutte contre le chômage en matière aussi
de plan de cohésion sociale faut savoir
que nous avons mis en construction plus
de 400 mille logements
donc ça ça prend du temps c'est pas
entre eux dans claque que les logements
ils se construisent loyer la politique
ça prend du temps il faut le voir rien
n'avait pas mal non on est voilà bien la
niaque non je crois que ça
et bien la balle mais alors pourquoi
chirac le garde villepin a votre avis il
faudrait vous lui posez la question
ouais non mais franz olivier giesbert
dans son livre dit que villepin sait des
choses terribles sur chirac et que c'est
pour ça qu'ils n'arrivent pas à s'en
débarrasser non je pense que le
président de la république d'abord
n'aime pas agir sous la pression non pas
les préférences que de toute façon
et puis c'est qu'il estime à voir en
dominique de villepin la personne de
circonstance
est ce que dans vos dossiers vous avez
abordé juger de l'exemple de
l'exemplarité je veux quand j'entends
votre ami par des racailles sur le
cadavre d'un jeune c'est pas vous
détourner ces noms mais je veux vous
parler mais je veux dire que j'ai
tendance à penser que à père de famille
qui veut avoir un tout petit peu
d'autorité sur son fils mais ton jeu ce
sont les gars ont fauché il faut qu'il
soit lui-même impeccable vous trouvez
pas qu'il ya une racaille d'en haut
tout est peint qui a des certaines des
amis de votre ami devrait être en prison
et au chili à gauche mais aussi à droite
et que et que d'une certaine manière
quand on veut être effectivement écouté
par la jeunesse il faut peut-être être
justement si on veut être respecté il
faut être respectable à ce que vous
dites soulève pour moi deux questions la
première en termes d'exemplarité
je pense que dans tous les milieux vous
aurez toujours des brebis galeuses dans
tous les milieux ensuite je crois que
les français qui se détournent de la
politique notamment le fait d'aller
voter ou ne serait-ce même que de
s'intéresser à ce que proposent les
responsables politiques vient aussi du
fait qu'ils ne croient plus en la
capacité des politiques à agir
et donc c'est vrai qu'il faut avoir un
cas une façon de gouverner et que avant
de proposer le moindre programme à
gauche comme à droite moi je les dis à
nicolas très clairement je pense qu'il
faudra dire avec quelle méthode il faut
gouverner et comment est-ce qu'on va
gouverner et on al impression qu en fait
personne ne peut répondre parce que le
président de la république qui doit lui
gouverner
lui qui gouverne ce premier ministre ce
présent à public mais il n'y a pas de
vraie affirmations de son rôle en la
matière et je crois que quand le
président de la république entrera
l'assemblée nationale et dira voilà le
programme que je vous propose que je
vous demande de cautionner et bien je
crois que le présent la république aura
une vraie autorité
les français auront un guide et qu'on
aura un vrai cap et c'est pour ça que je
crois vraiment en nicolas sarkozy voilà
qui sera notre guide donc nous l'avons
dit un jour près nous allons avoir un
vidéo je croise les doigts
vous pourrez pas qui peut se faire
battre par ségolène royal quand même des
connaisseurs le président avant non vous
avez peur un petit peu d'elle quand même
saveur non non je suis anéantie non mais
je vous assure que non je suis
complètement attend cela quand elle a eu
a eu des propos quant à expliquer un peu
ce qu'elle voulait faire il ya eu une
levée de boucliers de la part des
députés ump pro sarkozyste terrible et
même de lui il a quand il a fait sa
conférence de presse du ministre de
l'intérieur au lieu de parler des vrais
problèmes il a commencé à dire les
journalistes y ont posé la question soit
sur ségolène royal
il ya eu un truc il est philippe quand
même d'elle il a raison ce souper je
peux vous dire que l incarne sans doute
au parti socialiste c'est vrai que quand
vous regardez le parti socialiste c'est
un peu triste à pleurer quand même donc
elle incarne une image une modernité
je pense que c'est ce qui c'est ce
qu'incarne aussi nicolas sarkozy tu te
gêne
pourquoi je vous dis ça c'est parce
qu'il y ait eu un sondage d'enlever les
observateurs la semaine dernière assez
étonnant quand même 74% des chinois
c'est à dire les anciens maoïstes la 74
% des chinois sont pour l'économie de
marché 71% des américains sont pour
l'économie de marché 65 66 % des grands
pays européens espagne allemagne
angleterre sont pour l'économie de
marché en france il ya que 36 % des gens
tirent la moitié des chinois qui sont
pour l'économie de marché la soie la
france est très en avance
elle a compris que l'économie de marché
s'était pas un truc bien soit les très
en retard par rapport aux autres mais il
ya un problème avec 36% des gens
seulement pour l'économie de marché
c'est un problème pour des libéraux
comme vous quand maintenant je crois
qu'en france on n'a pas la conscience de
ce qu apporte vraiment une économie de
marché et il ya surtout une très
mauvaise connaissance du fonctionnement
de l'entreprise et de ce que peut
apporter
une entreprise et on a un système qui
est un peu qui tangue puisqu'on parle
toujours de notre modèle social dont on
sait très bien qu'il est défaillant avec
le nombre de chômeurs que nous avons
encore en france et on est toujours en
train de penser à nos acquis sociaux à
se tendre dispose l'assistanat
alors que on voit bien que notre système
est défaillant les gens sont comme ça
c'est parce qu'ils se sont ils n'ont
jamais été vivra ni en chine pour
beaucoup d'entre vous pouvez le dire ni
même dans les pays de l'est moi j'ai une
amie qui est venue des pays de l'est y
encore quelques années ils avaient des
tickets d'alimentation et donc c'est
vrai que lorsque vous avez connu quand
même
l'abondance vous vous rendez même plus
compte que vous avez l'abondance que
vous pouvez avoir accès aux soins que
vous pouvez avoir assez accès moi on est
passé d'un sujet de consommation elle a
juste dit de convoitises pas mal
oui je peux mettre dans son one man show
tu rajoutes rang derrière il ya un pays
où en ce moment on est en pleine
économie de marché où l'offre s'adapte à
la demande ou la main d'oeuvre circulent
librement
c'est l'allemagne avec la prostitution
là il ya de l'offre et de la demande
ah oui j'ai lu commander un article
écrit par une dame du parti socialiste
sur la parité des machins les femmes
il ya un mec un moment qui prend la
parole parce que elle dit que les
prostituées sont des femmes
à juste titre d'ailleurs qu'on a fourché
si je la ferai pas malheur de la
prostituée et lui dit le mec dieu quand
je mange un bifteck que j'ai vu cet été
non ça c'est vraiment le libéralisme
mais ce qui se passe en allemagne non
c'est la demande il ya un marché ben oui
vous avez des pays comme l'allemagne qui
ont choisi de légaliser la prostitution
d'autres qui sont revenus en arrière
comme la suède et aujourd'hui vous
apercevez que en suède vous avez encore
trois à quatre cents jeunes enfin femmes
qui viennent d'autres pays et le pays
d'à côté et la finlande c'est 15 à 17
milles donc que c'est vrai que en
revenant sur la légalisation de la
prostitution et en condamnant le client
puisque là-bas il s'agit de punir le
client est bien la prostitution a chuté
de 80%
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus